this is Jocko podcast number 213 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening
men this stuff that some sources sling
around about America wanting out of this
war not wanting to fight is a crock of
bullshit Americans love to fight
traditionally all Americans love the
sting in clash of battle you are here
today for three reasons first because
you are here to defend your homes and
your loved ones second you are here for
your own self-respect because you would
not want to be anywhere else
third you are here because you are real
men and all real men like to fight when
you here every one of you were kids you
all admired the champion marble player
the fastest runner the toughest boxer
the big league ball players and the
all-american football players americans
love a winner americans will not
tolerate a loser americans despise
cowards americans play to win all of the
time i wouldn't give a hoot in hell for
a man who lost and laughed
that's why americans have never lost nor
will ever lose a war for the very idea
of losing is hateful to an american you
are not all going to die only 2% of you
right here today would die in major
battle death must not be feared death in
time comes to all men yes every man is
scared in his first battle if he says
he's not he's a liar some men are
cowards but they fight the same as brave
men or they get to hell slam
out of them watching men fight who are
just as scared as they are the real hero
is the man who fights even though he is
scared some men get over their fright
and a minute under fire for some it
takes an hour for some it takes days but
a real man will never let his fear of
death overpower his honor his sense of
duty to his country and his innate
manhood battle is the most magnificent
competition in which a human being can
indulge it brings out all that is the
best and it removes all that his base
Americans pride themselves on being he
men and they are he men remember that
the enemy is just as frightened as you
are and probably more so they are not
supermen all through your army careers
you might have bitched about what you
call chickenshit drilling that like
everything else in the army has a
definite purpose that purpose is
alertness alertness must be bred into
every solider I don't give a fuck for a
man who's not always on his toes you men
are veterans or you wouldn't be here you
are ready for what's to come a man must
be alert at all times if he expects to
stay alive if you're not alert sometime
a Germans son of an asshole bitch is
gonna sneak up behind you and beat you
to death with a sock full of shit there
are four hundred neatly marked graves
somewhere in Sicily all because one man
went to sleep on the job but their
German graves because we caught the
bastard asleep before they did an army
is a team it lives
sleeps eats and fights as a team
this individual heroic stuff is pure
horseshit the vilest bastards who write
that kind of stuff for The Saturday
Evening Post don't know anything more
about real fighting under fire than they
do about fucking we have the fine
food the finest equipment the best
spirit and the best men in the world why
by god I actually pity those poor sons
of bitches we're going up against by God
I do my men don't surrender I don't want
to hear of any soldier under my command
being captured unless he's been hit even
if you are hit you can still fight back
that's not just bullshit either the kind
of man that I want my command is just
like the lieutenant in Libya who with a
Luger against his chest jerked off his
helmet swept the gun aside with one hand
and busted the hell out of the crowd
with his helmet then he jumped on the
gun and went out and killed another
German before they knew what the hell
was coming off and all that time this
man had a bullet through a lung there
was a real man all of the heroes are not
storybook combat fighters either every
single man in this army plays a vital
role don't ever let up don't ever think
that your job is unimportant
every man has a job to do and he must do
it every man is a vital link in the
great chain what if every Chuck driver
suddenly decided that he didn't like the
whine of those shells overhead turned
yellow and jumped headlong into a ditch
the Cowardly bastard would say hell they
won't miss me just one man and thousands
but what if every man fought that way
where the hell would we be now what
would our country our loved ones our
homes even the world be like no god damn
it Americans don't think like that every
man does his job every man serves the
hole every department every unit is
important in the vast scheme of this war
the Ordnance men are needed to supply
the guns and machinery of war to keep us
rolling the quartermaster is needed to
bring up food and clothes because where
we are going
there isn't a hell of a lot to steal
every last man on KP has a job to do
even the one who heats our water to keep
us from getting the GI shits each man
must not think only of himself but also
his buddy fighting beside him
we don't want yellow cowards in this
army they should be killed off like rats
if not they will go home after this war
and breed more cowards the brave men
will breed more brave men kill off the
goddamn cowards and we will have a
nation of brave men one of the bravest
men I ever saw was a fellow on top of a
telegraph pole in the midst of a furious
firefight in Tunisia I stopped and asked
what the hell he was doing up there at a
time like that
he answered fixing the wire sir I asked
isn't it a little unhealthy right about
now he answered yes sir but the goddamn
wire has to be fixed
I asked don't those planes straight from
the road bother you and he answered no
sir but you sure as hell do now there
was a real man a real soldier there was
a man who devoted all he had to his duty
no matter how seemingly insignificant
his duty might appear at the time no
matter how great the odds and you should
have seen those trucks on the road to
Tunisia those drivers were magnificent
all day and all night they rolled over
those son of a bitch and roads never
stopping never faltering from their
course with shells bursting all around
them all the time we got through on good
old American guts many of those men
drove for over 40 consecutive hours
these men weren't combat men but they
were soldiers with a job to do they did
it
and one hell of a way they did it they
were part of a team without team effort
without them the fight would have been
lost all of the links in the chain
pulled together and the chain became
unbreakable don't forget you men don't
know that I'm here no mention of that
fact is to be made in any letters the
world is not supposed to know what the
hell happened to me I'm not supposed to
be commanding this army I'm not even
supposed to be here in England let the
first bastards to find out be the
goddamn Germans someday I want to see
them raise up on their piss-soaked hind
legs and how Jesus
it's the goddamn third army again and
that son of a fucking bitch Patton we
want to get the hell over there the
quicker we clean up this goddamn mess
the quicker we can take a little jaunt
against the purple pissing Japs and
clean out their nests too before the
goddamn Marines get all the credit
sure we want to go home we want this war
over with the quickest way to get it
over with is to get the bastards who
started it the quicker they are whipped
the quicker we can go home the shortest
way home is through Berlin and Tokyo and
when we get to Berlin
I am personally going to shoot that
paper hanging son of a bitch Hitler just
like I'd shoot a snake when a man is
lying in a shell hole if he just stays
there all day a German will get to him
eventually
the hell with that idea the hell with
taking it my men don't dig foxholes I
don't want them to foxholes only slow up
an offensive keep moving and don't give
the enemy time to dig one either we'll
win this war but we'll win it only by
fighting and by showing the Germans that
we got more guts than they have or will
ever have we're not just gonna shoot the
sons of bitches we're gonna rip out
their living goddamn guts and use them
to grease the treads of our tanks we're
gonna murder those lousy hung
cocksuckers by the bushel fucking basket
war is a bloody killing business you've
got to spill their blood or they will
spill yours rip them up the belly shoot
them in the guts
when shells are hitting all around you
and you wipe the dirt off your face and
realize that instead of dirt it's the
blood and guts of what was once your
best friend beside you you'll know what
to do I don't want to get any messages
saying I am holding my position we are
not holding a goddamn thing let the
Germans do that we are advancing
constantly and we are not interested in
holding on to anything except the
enemy's balls we are going to twist his
balls and kick the living shit out of
him all the time
our basic plan of operation is to
advance and keep
advancing regardless of whether we have
to go over under or through the enemy
we're gonna go through him like crap
through a goose
like shit through a tinhorn from time to
time there will be some complaints that
we are pushing our people too hard I
don't give a good goddamn about such
complaints I believe in the old sound
rule that an ounce of sweat will save a
gallon of blood the harder we push the
more Germans we will kill the more
Germans we kill the fewer of our men
will be killed
pushing means fewer casualties I want
you all to remember that there is one
great thing that you men will all be
able to say after this war is over
and you are home once again you will be
thankful that 20 years from now when you
are sitting by the fireplace with your
grandson on your knee and he asks you
what you did in the great World War two
you won't have to Koff shift him to the
other knee and say well your granddaddy
shovel shit in Louisiana no sir you can
look him straight in the eye and say son
your granddaddy rode with the great
Third Army and the son of a goddamn
bitch named Georgie Patton
all right you sons of bitches you all
know how I feel I'll be proud to lead
you wonderful guys in battle anytime
anywhere that is all
and that speech was delivered in June of
1944 clearly by General George S Patton
in England and he actually delivered
that speech multiple times and this is
one version of it George Patton if you
don't know who it is podcast 9 we
covered his book war as I knew it and
you probably heard the shortened version
of that speech in the movie Patton with
George C Scott which is which is good
not as good as the original oh they
actually they actually sanitized the the
speech in the movie for Hollywood and
for the American public which is
interesting it's interesting that they
sanitized what someone says in a war
movie even though the war movie is
literally about killing killing people
lots of people but General Patton he he
knew and understood the power of
language especially bad language his
nephew asked his son this is a another
thing I read that his nephew asked him
about his use of profanity and Patton
said when I want my men to remember
something important to really make it
stick I give it to them double dirty it
may not sound nice to some bunch of
little old ladies an afternoon tea party
but it helps my soldiers to remember you
you can't run an army without profanity
and it has to be eloquent profanity an
army without profanity couldn't fight
its way out of a piss soaked paper bag
as for the comments I make sometimes I
just by God get carried away with my own
eloquence
so yeah there's a time in place for
profanity
you know I when I was in the SEAL Teams
I used to swear a lot when making a
point
and when making a point obviously you
want to make it stick this is something
I think I've I think I've talked about
this before but I would bring my son out
to training events and I never swear in
front of my family like even right now I
don't swear in front of my family so
when my son was probably you know like
six years old seven years old and I'd
bring him out to a training site to
observe some training you know so he
could start getting some well getting
kind of inoculated to the loud noises
machine-gun fire teaching him this the
fundamentals of tactics and stuff so
when he'd come out and watch training
and then I would be debriefing and you
know it would just be f-bomb f-bomb
sentence half sentence f-bomb F bump I
remember the first time he saw me
debrief like that and it's also the
first time he probably saw me you know I
don't wanna use the word emotional but
he's the first time he saw real
intensity for me because you're trying
to make a point to the guys and I will
freely say that at the time I was I
would get really in the zone because I'm
thinking that the guys that I'm training
I want them to absorb the message
because I want them to go overseas and
get killed so you know there's some
levels of intensity that would that
would happen so yeah sometimes the the
language comes out and should have an
impact if you use it too much obviously
loses its impact so like I said we
covered Patton's book war as I knew it a
long time ago but
there's Patton didn't just write that
book he actually was a fairly prolific
writer and some of what he wrote wasn't
meant to be
literature it was things like general
instructions to his troops so I got some
of those for us to look at just because
they're you know they're good stuff so
this is one there's two that we're gonna
go over today this is from headquarters
third United States Army six March 1944
subject a letter of instruction letter
of instruction number one to Corps
division and separate unit commanders so
this is one that's written to the
commanders of this subordinate units
underneath Patton
starts off with general this letter will
orient you officers of higher echelons
in the principles of command combat
procedure and administration which
obtained in this army and will guide you
in the conduct of your several commands
part number two command leadership full
duty each in his appropriate sphere will
lead in person any commander who fails
to obtain his objective and who is not
dead or severely wounded has not done
his full duty that's by the way just how
he's kicking this thing off and we've
definitely talked about that one before
but there you go
welcome to working for George Patton if
you fail to obtain your objective and
you're not dead or severely wounded then
you haven't done your duty so that's
where that's the that's the basis on
which we're building this stuff
continues visits to the front the
commanding general or as chief of staff
never both at once and one member of
each of the General Staff sections
should visit the front daily to save
duplication the chief of staff will
designate the sector each is to visit
the function of these staff officers is
to observe not to meddle very important
don't go up there and stir
trying to make little changes know
you're up there to observe continuing in
addition to their own specialty they
must observe and report anything of
military importance remember too that
your primary mission as a leaders to see
with your own eyes and to be seen by the
troops while engaged in personal
reconnaissance so think about that not
just see what's going on you want them
to see you too that you're out there
with the troops next section is
execution in carrying out a mission the
promulgation of the order represents not
over 10 percent of your responsibilities
the remaining 90 percent consists of
assuring by means of personal
supervision on the ground by yourself
and your staff proper and vigorous
execution how important is that the
passing of the order is ten percent of
your duties the other 90 percent is
making sure it gets done mm-hmm you
don't hear that very often they already
told them what to do that's all that's
you know I passed the word man I passed
the word not my fault not my problem
wrong answer that's I only say 90
percent of your problem go ahead the one
one that I've maybe used I don't know
maybe heard I don't know it's like hey I
can only say it so many times you know
oh yeah that's a good one you know I've
told him a bunch of times yeah I said
the email I said the email no ten
percent of your responsibilities passing
the information 90 percent is assuring
by means of personal supervision on the
ground vigorous proper and vigorous
execution think about that next time you
you put out the word and then you kick
back into your chair a wrong answer next
year staff conferences I'm abbreviating
this thing daily at the earliest
possible moment that the g2 and g3 can
get their Maps posted so g2 and g3 those
are the that's Intel and opera
as soon as they can get their maps
posted a staff conference will be held
attended by the commanding general chief
of staff and the heads of all general
staff sections and he goes through who
those are then the reason I highlighted
this part because I'm not reading this
whole thing but he says any person
present with a statement to make will do
so briefly check not on there to talk
your honor to hear yourself talk you're
not in there so that the commanding
general the boss the CEO gets to see
that you're in there and you said
something smart actually just be quiet
and if you have to say something make it
brief
it's supposed to be a brief so it's
called a brief yeah and just to mention
that again I'm not reading this entire
thing but were eating some big chunks of
it talks about rest periods okay rest
periods and we know there's big
controversy from my world when it comes
to rest because once a day no that's
probably inaccurate probably between one
and three times a day someone via
various social media messaging whatever
hmm you know it says to me you know get
more rest and you don't sleep enough and
all these things mm-hmm otherwise you
know my world is gonna turn into a
disaster which you know waiting on that
one so here's what but and you know what
I always say of course it's hey it's in
the book discipline equals freedom field
man I wrote a book and said you need to
get sleep sleep is important without
sleep all these bad things happen I know
this and I propagate it all the time
sleep you know you're telling people not
sleep now I tell people see if all the
time you need to sleep to perform
optimally you need to sleep different
people need different amounts of sleep
well however much sleep you need get it
it's fine it's great I support it so his
patent here we go rest periods staff
personnel commissioned and enlisted who
do not rest do not last all sections
must run a duty roster and
enforce compliance the intensity of
staff operations during battle is
periodic at the army and core levels the
busiest times are the period from 1 to 3
hours after daylight and from 3 to 5
hours after dark in the lower echelon
and in the administrative and supply
staffs the time periods is different but
just as definite when the need arises
everyone when the need arises everyone
must work all the time but these
emergencies are not frequent unfit
Egemen lasts longer and work better at
high pressure so like I say like I tell
people all the time get sleep not bad
for you do you need to sleep until 9:00
no you don't well some people do depends
when you guys receive a return text from
you today
until I'm thinking was around 10 yeah am
I right or wrong
well you know you're probably right I
don't have those records we can check so
is that what time you woke up just out
of curiosity yes do you feel well rested
right now ready to perform yes ready to
bring your a-game yes sir I do this it's
a long story and it's worth it yeah okay
so were you up late last night watching
the fights no Connor was over early cars
fight was only 40 seconds long yeah I
could have been in bed at we're talking
9:00 I was I was going to bed and I
jumped like literally going to bed when
I seen the results come through okay but
I'm not used to going to sleep that
early so I ended up waking up in the
middle of night not being able to go
back sleep and then you know then you
hit the rest of it woke up it okay so
rest is important there you go it's an
order from Patton that you need to get
rest next section is a location of
command posts the farther forward the
farther forward the command posts are
located the last time is wasted in
driving to and from the front the ideal
situation would be for the army command
post to be within one half hours drive
in a command post and reconnaissance car
of the division command post the driving
time to the front and from the command
post the driving time to the front from
the command post of
lower units should be correspondingly
shorter much time and wires saved if
command posts of higher units are at or
near one of the command posts of the
next Oh Reginald so in why am I talking
about that because the reason is think
about how important communication is
between the senior leadership and the
frontline troops and when you have big
separation now what's nice these days
then he goes into a bunch of stuff
talking about when he's talking about
wire versus radio do you know what you
know what that means they used to
actually string out wire so if you had a
forward post two miles from me we would
string wire between the two of us so we
could talk like phone yeah like phone
whining like little phone wire and in
that opening speech when he's talking
about a guy in Tunisia putting the wire
up on a telephone that's what he's
talking about they because radios at
that time were way less way less
reliable than they are now so now we can
overcome a lot of this with technology
but just showing the importance of and
by the way he's not even talking about
wire he's talking about being able to go
there and see what's happening so
there's ways to overcome this I guess my
point in calling this out is showing how
important visible leadership is right
how important face-to-face is mmm from a
leadership perspective a combat
procedure next section Maps we are too
prone to believe that we acquire merit
solely through the study of maps in the
safe seclusion of a command post maps
are necessary in order to see the whole
panorama of battle and to permit
intelligent planning further and this is
very important a study of the map will
indicate where critical situations exist
or or are apt to develop and so indicate
where the commander should be in the
higher echelons a layered map of the
whole theater is reasonable to scale
showing roads railways streams talents
more useful in a large scale map
cluttered up without ground force so the
reason that I I put this in here is
looking
visibly visually at something real this
is a little bit of a little bit of a
justjust an eye-opener right
you have vert everything's virtual now
right we can look at virtual charts we
can see virtual diagrams we can see
virtual spreadsheets we can see market
data and and I get it and there's
there's many much of the time virtual
data is has superior some superior
qualities of it because you can
manipulate it you can watch it move you
can dig into it you can click on the
link right and see where the source of
the data and all that stuff is good all
I'm saying and the only reason I bring
this is up is because sometimes the the
the physical not the physical chart the
physical spreadsheet that you can look
at that you can put up on a wall and say
let's talk through this sometimes and
and part of this I think is just my
personality my the way that I you know
people have different types of learning
right my the way my brain works
sometimes to look at something that's
actually physically there mm-hmm
sometimes works better for me then the
virtual thing that I'm looking out on
the screen
yeah just throwing that out there I
don't know if you feel that way well I
feel like if you know when you're
talking about a map or even like a
diagram if I have it physically in front
of me and and then nu and then you're
feel obviously physically in front of me
so we're both physically there we can
kind of interact with it in the physical
world so I can point here and make a
good marking it with the pencil which
you can take that's what I'm saying like
now it is you can have a iPad right and
we could be marking that things up so
there's there's some closure the gap is
getting closed on this yeah yeah the
iPads it's closed but not really because
I've had only this big room and it's
like when you write on and it's it
there's that what we call like a barrier
like at very least like
logical barrier between the actual
document you know it feels like it even
though you're marquise not you know it's
a touchscreen seeking it feels like
here's one that this is a real simple
straightforward one the difference
between a physical checklist on a piece
of paper or on a whiteboard compared to
there's about five million apps
including native apps to your phone that
do checklist I personally think that I
find physical lists in a notebook or on
a whiteboard better what do you think I
think it's funny how you use the
expression native app was that correct
it's advanced it was that skirt that's
what they are right like Apple has I
don't believe it yeah it comes with it's
good oh yeah they should hang on tacked
me actually of course they should and I
could I could dial that where it would
be squared away very tactile right
that's what's going right with ya but
also the one of the problems is one of
the one of the disadvantages of those
kind of lists is because things are
hidden right like you you have to open
that list right yeah you can't see it so
you look at a project and you don't
really even see the depth of project
whereas if you have like a physical list
that you're looking at you say oh that
project is gonna is gonna take some
labor yeah I feel it for sure
I think I'm kind of used to the apps
though as far as like notes and whatever
I'm used to it so I think like anything
the more you get used to it the more
you're like oh I like this or whatever I
use the notes one so easy like when in
the SEAL Teams PowerPoint two started to
just run everything everything was
briefed on PowerPoint and that is one
time when you would look when you'd
bring the guys around to look at a map
or bring the guys around to look at an
image that's all that your can draw on
is so much clearer than just everyone
sitting there there's the
separation I guess you called it what
you call it a virtual separation there's
some separation barrier when you'd
actually pull out a a map and say here's
the route you'd be like drawing on there
and you'd say okay there's a hill over
here and people I don't know people seem
to get it better
same thing with something called the
force list which sounds really cool but
all it means is this is who's going on
this mission okay and also where they're
sitting in the vehicles the virtual
force list almost always sucked it was
almost always like slightly wrong and
they if people wouldn't know where that
but we would do it on a magnet board and
everybody had their own magnet I still
have my magnet for my first deployment
it says it's my magnet says just says
Jocko it's yellow well it's the magnets
Brown and then it says Jacque on its
off-center and like it looks like
somebody did it in like five minutes not
like this big high-speed thing right no
it's this really kind of rudimentary
magnet says jockle so when you get your
magnet that's just that's your mag
that's for the whole trip I'm making it
into a bigger deal than it is
but on that first deployment to Iraq
that was my magnet when I left I took
the magnet with me yeah because there's
some good memories with the magnet right
you see that thing in the because you
have on the on the dry erase board the
magnetic dry erase board you have
outlines of the vehicles and then you
just put your you know you put your
magnet gets put into position you look
at the board you know where you're at
right and most of the time you know I
was in vehicle two in the vehicle
commander's seat that's where I was most
of the time depending on what we were
doing sometimes I would be if I was like
the assault force commander I might be
in vehicle three but whatever but that
little magnet you know where it is right
now on your frigerator yes it is so when
I look go to the frigerator I remember
yeah that magnet and one of my buddies
named Johnny like one day he sent me a
picture of his magnet and I said a
picture of my back yeah wait what castle
okay so you need to make it's just a
circle no it's a square it's a rectangle
but is it like just a raw magnet though
or is it a magnet a raw magnet with with
what's it called you ever seen those
little machines where you make a label
make machine label-maker little there's
a little yellow label and the magnet
says jaakor huh boom there it is and
it's off-center that's what makes me
that's what's funny it's not like this
special thing it's like here here mmm
boom done yeah but it's like one of the
for lack of better terms for like better
term one of the trinkets of the missions
you know it's like one of the
memorabilia or whatever it might be I
don't know I'd have to think of this I'm
sure there's other trinkets but that is
well the one thing that I go yeah yeah
those are some yeah it's right there so
you get those kind all right something
that's abuse not major mass abuse but
it's like as an essential part of the
whole and we made task unit bruiser the
first thing I was okay guys we need
magnet boards and you know everyone's
like thinking uh whatever we'll just use
the computer and all that stuff and it's
so much harder
imagine this you've got 40 people 40
little names and you're dragging them
around on PowerPoint and so what you
deleted one by accident where'd that one
go it's from a different the magnets
like you have a space on the magnet
board oh these guys aren't going on the
mission there they're over here but you
can see them and then you say wait we
need another machine gunner oh cool
who's the machine gunner Smith's machine
gunner put them in you in the turret
boom we're good yeah if the physical
representation is important tint yep
yeah I know it is okay okay so I can you
know Photoshop is right I dunno what it
is okay it's not a native app though no
series now so that's the aftermarket one
for sure
so the okay so Photoshop is like really
when you when you get used to it it's
like simple you know but here's that
here's the difference and I just
distilled it down it's the interface the
interface that's what makes it like
that's the barrier even if it's a simple
interface like PowerPoint you know
there's still an interface you got to
learn how to use PowerPoint right so
even after you learn how to use
PowerPoint you still have to interface
with the the system you do you know so
but with a physical thing there is no
interface there's just boom boom we're
doing it look if I want this little
choco magnet to physically move to the
front seat that watch me physically
moved
the front Sue Snell interface that
happens the exact reality yeah so the
feedback is instant big as kind of a big
deal I remember I thought well I'll have
to reconfirm this with Lafe but there
was I wouldn't say resistance but
questions you know because I think I
went out and just bought magnets for
task unit bruiser like okay here's the
magnet here's the back and the more the
magnet boards were expensive to I want
to say they were I want to say a big
magnet board costs over a hundred
dollars yeah you know there's a lot of
money when you're in the Navy and you
got three kids like like 100 bucks is no
joke oh yeah for just a board yeah but
well worth every penny
yeah every penny so do you because you
like to read physical books - I do right
and I'm not saying necessarily compared
to audible by like I use the Kindle
right there's a little interface going
on right there - but technically the
it's quicker there's less physical work
to use a Kindle than a book yeah I I
think what would have to happen for me
is I would have to use a Kindle or
whatever Digital Reader fan until I
learned the interface because right now
I can't stand those things yeah well I
do on the phone the Kindle app or
whatever but the yeah yeah yeah it's the
same thing you know actually I think the
actual Kindle is bigger isn't better you
know what's interesting what my kids do
for books for school and whatnot they
read the book as they listen to the
audiobook huh which is interesting yeah
we could you know what I did that one
time you know what book I did it for
fields of fire by James Webb yeah I was
listening to it and reading it and I
don't know why I don't know why I
decided to do that maybe because it was
a fiction book I don't know but for some
reason that's what I did well there's
all kinds of like different reading
methods you know there's all these
methods like to read whether it be
faster or improved comprehension you
know this way and one of them is to skim
like rudimentary skim but kind of like
literally like three seconds per page
even one second per V okay what is that
skim the whole thing first and it
creates this idea of what
everything's about you skip it first
then you're gonna burn you read yeah you
know just kind of I was gonna really
throw that idea out the window oh just a
minute and then leave this okay actually
so when I get a book a potential book
for the podcast I will say I do some of
that yeah I'll be looking through it
because you know the book for the
podcast gonna have to be a good book
right and I got to make sure that it
fits in with the podcasts right so I'll
skim it and look for scenes yeah then I
go over that's a good one and then you
know what I do is I read the end it's
jacked up as that as spoilers I spoiled
the book for myself even though most of
the time you kind of know what's gonna
happen I mean it's a war book it's like
oh it's World War two cool we know
what's gonna happen right if the first
person person that's writing it they
live to write the book so you know
they're alive yeah most of the time
there's been a few where the person you
know this is recovered from them or
whatever but yeah so I I skim through
them and then I find the information but
I can't I haven't been able to prep for
a podcast virtually yet hmm
all of them have been even though
there's one where I was traveling and I
decided I was gonna do something that I
had it on PDF and I went through the
whole thing and like I outlined it and
stuff while virtually and then when I
got home I rented it out it yeah yeah
there must be something with the like
the relationship between you know the
material the physical material in your
eyeballs or something so let's just say
this from a leadership perspective
here's the takeaway if the virtual
methodology is not working perhaps try a
physical version that's gonna be my
suggestion after all this after all this
assessment of the general patton's yep
words Jack alright now we get to plans
and what's cool about this his plans his
sections so like the last sections
couple paragraphs long the section
before that couple paragraphs long the
section while planning arguably the most
important section to be given by the
commander of how we're gonna plan this
is that one of the shortest sections
here plans plans must be simple and
flexible
I I got that I utilized that right there
so much it was ridiculous and it was so
powerful to be able to say hey look cuz
because in the SEAL Teams they would
lean towards wanting and not just in
SEAL Teams they people do this in
business all the time they want to make
they want to make plans ultra detailed
because they think the more detail to
put in the plan the better the plan will
be executed that's actually wrong the
more detail you put in the plate look
you need to have some level deal but if
you go overboard with the detail now
you're working on things that don't
matter you're trying to do things in a
way that don't matter you can't do that
so that's how he starts our plans must
be simple and flexible cuz nothing's
gonna go the way you expect it to go and
then he says this actually they only
form aid Adam plane from which you build
as necessity directs or opportunity
offers so the plan is actually is barely
anything it's like hey this is the
general idea and then we'll make
adjustments as a necessity director as
we have opportunities they should be
made by the people who are going to
execute them right incredible once again
these are things that I did and I when I
read that I thought man that so lucky
that I did that because to force a plan
down someone's throat or to make a sort
of even worse take the problem and
multiply it exponentially force the plan
down on the people below you that is
very detailed and doesn't have any
flexibility that's just failure I'd get
to see that man I'd get to see some some
tasking a commander coming through
training and look the guy's not a bad
human guy actually wants to good in fact
wanting to do a good job can drive you
to try and make a more detailed plan and
force it down onto your people that
that's not necessarily a person that's a
bad leader they just haven't learned the
lesson yet that might be a person that's
super engaged wants to do a great job
overachiever Hey look I know how to do
this acta puts together this highly
detailed plan that's not a good call man
there's nothing against the person but
you have to do with that purse
just show them the light right you're
gonna bring him to the light okay so
then he goes through because through a
section on reconnaissance you can never
have too much reconnaissance use every
means available before during and after
battle reports must be facts not
opinions negative as well as positive do
not believe intercepts blindly
cross-check sometimes message are sent
out to be intercepted so a bunch of good
little things to think about their
reports must not must be facts not
opinions there's a a term that used the
military it's appears to be a TB so
you'd see a person holding something you
you're pretty sure it's a weapon but you
don't know then you say appears to be a
weapon it appears to be a weapon or you
say you know people moving into a in a
appears to be a tactical position right
so it's just one of those little things
because there's a huge difference
between me saying they were moving
weapons into the building or they were
moving what appeared to be weapons in
the building yeah it's like it's not an
established value an established fact
and if you remember when we talked about
the me live massacre that's one of those
things where the difference between
appears to be and this is could be can
kind of cause those kind of problems
same thing with with police shootings
right someone saying hey this guy has a
weapon yeah
or this guy appears to have a weapon
there's a big difference between those
two things
yeah yeah the lead like legal when
they're speaking like legal terms
they're always like super careful about
that like all the say allegedly or you
know like even though the guy just did
it on camera yeah the suspect even that
that's like a suspect I'm watching it
right here on the video yeah no no it's
not proven in the court of law yet so
you know it's like a legal one
if next sections about orders formal
orders formal orders will be preceded by
letters of instruction and by personal
conferences in this way the whole
purpose of the operation will be made
clear together with the mission to be
accomplished by each major unit in this
way if communication breaks down during
combat each commander can and must so
act as to attain the general objective
this is a little something we called
decentralized command right everyone has
to know what the main objective is so
when communication breaks down which it
will we can still move forward the order
itself will be short accompanied by a
sketch it tells what to do not how it is
really a Memorandum and assumption of
responsibility by the issuing commander
so a bunch of key things there the order
supposed to be short the orders
accompanied by a sketch once again we
get this visual representation thing
seems to be important mm-hmm and this is
an important one tells what to do not
how I have to brief people on that one
all the time so and and you'll also
notice this foam rollers will be
preceded by letters of instruction and
by personal conferences so you know a
trick question that I asked companies
when I'm working with them what's better
form of communication email or voice or
face-to-face and of course everyone says
voice voice worse they say face-to-face
I'll say what's more what's a better
form of communication email or phone
call and if it was all phone calls so
much better right that's that's
everyone's gut instinct oh yeah talking
to someone so much more clear and then I
say okay here's the problem with just
talking if we just talk I say one thing
you hear something else which happens
all the time so that's why I follow up
when you and I have a conversation I
followed up with an email and say hey
just want to make sure we're good on
this
sure that we're gonna do a B and C yeah
and then you say uh I thought we were
doing a B and D and I said oh no sorry
my fault I didn't explain it clearly so
that's one way the other thing is the
opposite is also true
if I just send you an email I want you
to do this this there's no tone there's
no expression you might not see the
importance I might have written it
clearly so after if it's important I
send you an email and I say hey echo
just following up to make sure that
we're on the same page cuz I'm not
always the best at writing stuff but
when the email I just sent you I wanted
to make sure that you know that you
understood it was a B and C did that
come through and you're like oh yeah
definitely
or you're like wait a second so you want
to use both and that's exactly what he's
saying here you you write it you speak
it you speak it you write it yeah yeah
you ever see those guys or talk to those
guys where you talk to them they're all
excited you can totally tell and then
when they text you it's like two three
sometimes one-word answers you know and
so you're kind of like oh man he must be
kind of mad because his tone now is way
different than when I was talking on or
whatever yeah you sort of make your own
interpretation of the thing depending on
like maybe I don't know maybe how you do
it or something like that but some
people that's just how they write you
know first it'll be like hey get back to
me period and it's like dang this guy's
mad he wants me to get back to him my
son in text is like just the most
horrible yeah like you okay jack then
again no but you do express certain
tones more comedic I think for comedic
effect well in my experience anyway I'm
sure you know you have a whole thing but
yeah when I was texting him your boy he
same deal like he was like the younger
version a yeah he just says no what'd he
say he was in a surf contest the other
day and you know so he's I was somewhere
else and you know I'm texting hey did
you make it through the first tee cuz
the way surf contest worked you surfing
heats and you have to get in the top
three and each heat to advance and then
eventually you get to the finals so I'm
texting him and this is a teenage boy
right so it's not like he's not on his
phone
right I'm texting hey how'd you do hey
how'd the first heat go did you make it
through nothing heard nothing heard
nothing heard all day
finally the end of the day I say hey did
you finish the contest how did you do he
writes back got to mmm which meant he
got 2nd place in the context it's all
said office all small letters yeah how
does it even do small letters because it
automatically caps somehow on his phone
no automatic apples as it says got to
which is the 17 year old boys way of
saying hey Dad I got 2nd place today
thanks for showing some concern and I
appreciate your support as a father and
had a great time that's all in there
right no got to so anyways you know
follow up with and you know then when I
called him later or whatever he's like
oh yeah at first you know he's give me
all the details right got to it knee
talks about something called fragmentary
orders frag orders after the initial
order you will seldom get another form
or order but you may get fragmentary
orders in writing or orally by phone or
personally take down all oral orders and
repeat them back have your juniors do
the same to you again can you imagine
how many times and how important this is
that this guy General Patton by the way
is saying listen when you get told to do
something write it down and read it back
that's just the standard operating
procedure of life when you get told to
do something write it down read it back
there's nothing that instills more
confidence in me then when um keep
telling somebody what to do and there
take your notes on it that's just you go
okay cool I can barely even trust a look
I'm not saying this in a bad way but I
barely even trust waitresses or waiters
when I'm telling them what I want and
they're just looking at me like I got
this yeah I'm always nervous oh yeah I
guess maybe in really net right not you
know sometimes I can't help myself but
I'll say oh you must be
you know nobody I got you right and
they're looking at me like they do this
all the time right
it's do you think that that's like a
move like a flex right for you know
service industry one that's like oh yeah
like I'm so good a little bit of Lackey
and also just a skill right right right
yeah they're showing off the skill yeah
and sometimes I don't think they're
showing off sometimes I just think
they're that's what they do that's what
they're they're just trying to you know
they're saying like yeah I got this
that's what they do it on an individual
level or as a company because that
individual both that individuals like
hey I you know good to because you know
I always want I always want to order
right now you know when they come over
to offer you water I want to order that
I don't know what's I don't the I don't
want to go through the sequence when you
come to me I want to order because I
already know what I'm getting I'm
getting a Caesar salad and a ribeye
that's already happening so we already
know that walking into the place I don't
need to look at the menu I don't want to
look familiar
so when they come over and and I say
they say you know they start pouring my
water I say I'm actually ready to order
and sometimes they just say okay go kind
of a pro move right I think over the
time I think over time I become more
comfortable with it and now when someone
does that I know they're a pro so I
think I guess now I'm good with it
I didn't used to be you know when I
transitioned from eating at let's say
what the restaurants where there's no
pros right like a normal restaurant
people are just in there they're taking
notes right there oh this isn't like
there this is their secondary job
whatever their teenager whatever like
there this is they're just doing this to
make whatever some extra money when you
go to a real restaurant where there's
pros I have confidence in those people
yeah until there's a mistake oh yes yes
but and I think and I know this comes
with my wife literally not yesterday
before when it went ever very recently
either yesterday before we sushi
restaurant it was our first time there
it was nice inside but it was like it
was kind of new casual trendy nice okay
that kind little nervous a little kind
of minimalist but it's like you don't
know if it's like is this a high-end
restaurant or just super trained so they
the jury was still out on that whole
situation so whatever and then you know
he pulled one of those I respected him
for it I like when they do that okay on
that level
but there is a question mark in the back
man because I'm one of the annoying type
order you've got special things yeah you
know you got to this and can I have
extra this and I don't want to I don't
want to cope but until the five cousins
also kind of like chess you know a good
chess players looking at the chessboard
in chunks so they don't have to remember
every piece there remembering whole
whole schemes of maneuver that are gonna
happen yeah when you're ordering in the
restaurant when you say I want steak and
see like they already in it so they all
they actually are remembering is when
you say oh I'd like the peppercorn sauce
medium right that's the only thing they
really need to remembrance they
remembered everything else yeah so yeah
yeah yeah and I'm with you though like
one night one if someone's like boom
boom they're on it and they bring
everything especially other annoying
sights okay so me and my wife's like
this too more she'll be like can I she
want different sauces you don't normally
get with it you know like that kind me
too and then yeah I know it's a pain to
have those specialty the quest right
it's so it makes it so much but
nonetheless if if they come through with
that boom without being caught on what
reminded and how even miss a dude like
it sounds kinda sending but my thing is
I don't give you what you asked for
what do you just suck it up and just
deal with it or do you say something
which one what what I mean say something
okay I can get the sriracha or whatever
or the wasabi whatever but they don't do
they act super guilty or they act just
super annoyed oh I don't remember any
time anyone acting annoyed but have you
I've done that where I've asked for some
little specific thing and then they
don't deliver and then I say hey you
know I actually asked for this and
they're like and they're acting annoyed
at me yeah yeah I can see how that can
see why I deserve it right when somebody
messes something up I'm kind of like
okay well that's just this is how it is
all yeah I feel like I'm jamming up the
whole system because I used to work
service entry long time so they you know
you have a system and it works so good
especially when you're dealing with like
people after people you know group and
group it like all day and the
system works so good and it's probably
formulated out off of like something
something that everyone's cooperating
with they'll tell you that it's working
and I'm not cooperating I feel cuz I'm
the customer who's not technically
Crawford you know because it starts with
what drinks hi everybody sit down you
know one minute should be like one
minute water's coming SWA Turks you want
anything to drink besides water blah
blah blah
me I'm like my appetizer but yeah so
bright I'm the kind of like yeah I do
want to drink but how's this the drink I
want the drink to come with the food
already jamming up the whole system so
they should be annoyed with me in fact I
want to say they should be but if
they're annoyed with me I understand I'm
annoying already and it doesn't stop
there
they'll bring out the sushi or whatever
will be like hey can I have two sides
extra wasabi side of eel sauce and
teriyaki sauce some teriyaki so it's
like probably Skyy I just ordered like
everybody's been playing the game you're
over here doing all this stuff I'm over
you're trying to memorize your order
without writing it down and you're worth
doing this you know so I understand but
I think what my to my point earlier
there don't have to memorize your holder
they're just like oh this guy's got
these two things that are outside the
normal box there's only really two
things afternoon I think yeah I think
that's what happens I think you're right
this all this means look you're a leader
you're a junior leader your boss is
going to tell you to do something do
yourself a favor
do your boss a favor don't make him
wonder if you're a waiter or waitress
that can handle the scenario
don't make them wonder that then you
could whip out your notebook and you go
hey boss let me just read this back to
you what you told me because I want to
get this honor % right in here and say
okay awesome up the confidence level
could any tell that's my recommendation
next section warning orders warning
orders are vital and must be issued in
time this requirement applies applies
not only to combat units but also the
surgeon signal officer quartermaster and
ordnance officer
engineering officer who must get warning
orders promptly they too have plans to
make any warning orders is the initial
thing that you tell the troops hey we
might be attacking get ready for this
that's a warning order I sent somebody a
warning order the other day oh yeah I
remember was you know I literally
because he's another team guy mm-hmm and
I said hey here's a warning order oh
yeah you call it a warning or classify
there's the warning order yeah cuz I was
just giving her heads-up we got a
a possible scenario I'll do that too
I'll say new mission though like I'll
indicate what this is is coming you know
so here's the thing with that new
mission means you're gonna tell them
exactly what's going on mm-hmm
warning order you give them just because
warning order is just a heads-up right
like this might this might not happen
here's kind of the general thing we
think should be happening
you can give it to them a little bit
earlier new mission means now you got
all this prep to do because you didn't
get a warning order step up your game
next keep troops informed use every
means before and after combat to tell
troops what they're going to do and what
they have done boom there you go I
believe there's a whole section in that
in the book called leadership strategy
and tactics and I think it's literally
called to keep the troops informed next
administration supply I was thinking all
you know I'll skip this because whatever
no here's what it says the onus of
supply rests equally on the giver and
the taker that is so important instead
of hey we hey where's our dang supplies
it's their fault it's like no actually
it's my fault mmm and then he says this
Ford units must anticipate needs and ask
for supplies in time they must stand
ready to use all their means to help who
supplies the supply service must get the
things asked for it to the right place
at the right time they they must do more
by reconnaissance they will anticipate
demands and start the supplies up before
they're called for so this is what's
interesting you see both sides have to
take extreme ownership of the delivery
of the supplies and what you get is you
get interlocking fields of fire
overlapping Oh interlocking and
overlapping fields of fire don't you
think exactly what you want yeah meaning
overlapping fields of fire meaning years
I'm shooting to the north west and
you're shooting also part of your
coverages to the north west but then
you're to get a little bit more to the
east too so we're both
looking and we're overlapping
overlapping fields of fire that's what
we want and that's what that's what when
you have extreme ownership on both sides
you get overlapping fields of fire which
means the chances of something being
missed are less because the fields of
fire are overlapping is both got it come
never said that before it's good yeah
cuz even feel the fire overlap almost
like I'm gonna clean up that analogy and
that's gonna end up being a very
powerful analogy yeah it's like you both
got it covered you know you both gotta
come out I say something close to it a
lot me which which is you know I say
look when every person when everyone in
the chain of command is taking ownership
of the problems the problems get solved
there's more to it than that
because when you take ownership of the
problem and I take ownership of the same
problem
there's overlapping fields of fire and
we will kill that problem because you're
gonna see it from your angle maybe you
get say 80% of it solved I got that
other 20% yeah doubly and sure yes and
then it says this the desperate
determination to succeed is just as
vital to supply as it is to the firing
line
the desperate determination meaning the
guys in the front line we know their
lives are in danger
supply has to have the same attitude
Logistics wins Wars they got a chunk in
here on replacements they got a chunk in
here on hospitals they got a chunk in
here on decorations decorations are for
the purpose of raising the fighting
value of troops therefore they must be
awarded promptly have a definite officer
on your staff educated in writing
citations and see that they get through
boy we don't do a good job of this
anymore
the awards process is painful next
section is on discipline anyway so going
back to two decorations real quick
that means when you're running a
business when you're running a team and
someone does something well recognizing
for it quickly promptly it means
something the next section is called
discipline which were definitely fond of
there's only one kind of discipline per
discipline if you do not enforce and
maintain discipline you are potential
murderers you must set the example check
believe me Patton is is into discipline
he's we're gonna read another section he
goes into that's all he's got in here
next section rumors reports based on
information secured through
reconnaissance conducted after dark
should be viewed with skepticism the
same thing applies to reports from
walking wounded and stragglers these
latter seemed seek to justify themselves
by painting alarming pictures why that's
it
so that's a that's a very astute
observation right okay guys that are
coming back that are wounded or walking
wounded or was stragglers there telling
I could so bad because they don't want
to look bad he says it is risky and
usually impossible to move reserves
during darkness on every call for help
units cannot be wholly destroyed a night
attack they must stick launcher
counter-attack after daylight and
subsequent to adequate reconnaissance
and see it it's coordinate that's a good
one that but what that basically means
is to me when you defeat someone you
need to go in there and like finish it
off a hundred percent hmm condition and
by that he means conditioning it by that
it means physical conditioning high
physical condition is vital to victory
there are more tired core and division
commanders than there are tired core and
divisions fatigue makes cowards of us
all men in condition do not tire and the
last one is courage do not take counsel
of your fears which he seems to write
that all the time and it's there's a
good reason for it you're gonna be
afraid don't listen to it mmm don't
negotiate with it
signed who 10 a general US Army
commanding ok so that that was letter of
instruction number one and this now
we're gonna jump into this one came out
a little bit later letter of instruction
number two this letter stresses those
tactical and administrative usages which
combat experience has taught myself and
the officers who have served under me to
consider vital and then it says you will
not simply mimeograph this and call it a
day
you are responsible that these usages
become habitual in your command even in
war 1944 we're getting ready to invade
France and fight the GNAT Nazis we're
going to embark on the most on the
largest attack of soul ever in the
history of the world that's what we're
doing and guess what he's still saying
look you can't just mimeograph basic
call date even even with all that you
got officers that are like ok hey the
boss put out some word here you can read
it know this idea of hey just putting
out the word being enough this reflects
what he said last time about 10% 90% 10
percents given the order 90% is
personally ensuring it gets done taking
ownership of it that's what he's talking
about that is exactly what he's talking
about
ok so he starts it off with that then he
goes right into discipline which as I
said he's a a believer in the power of
discipline so he says there's only one
sort of discipline perfect especially
I'm reading it kind of without much
vigor because I've read it before he
says at all time I'm gonna read it again
with vigor because it deserves to some
there is only one sort of discipline
perfect discipline men cannot have good
battle discipline and poor
administrative discipline
Oh imagine that you can't just be all
lacks cabeza go back behind garrison
doing the administrative stuff
and expect you're gonna have discipline
when it's for combat related subjects
you gotta have it across the board good
discipline is based on pride and a
profession of arms on meticulous
attention to details and on mutual
respect and confidence discipline must
be a habit so ingrained that it is
stronger than the excitement of battle
or the fear of death have you ever seen
the movie soldier this could be a good
one you're gonna have to go watch this
one yeah you know what which one the
movie is called soldier it stars a guy
named it stars a famous guy and I can't
think of his name right now but he was
in Tombstone and it's not a good he
looks like kind of like Patrick Swayze
Val Kilmer no no he's real famous he's
really famous actor well Tim still knows
Kurt Russell yes Kurt Russell okay okay
so Kurt Russell's in this movie soldier
you gotta watch this movie yeah this
movie is a really good movie okay
think about what I'm saying right now
yeah this movies are really good not
it's not only surprising that I'm saying
that because it's like a sci-fi movie
yeah okay I did it's a sci-fi movie
it's it's pretty on the surface you got
okay
you can barely you it's a kind of movie
you'd flip through in the video store me
like whatever another it looks just like
any other cheesy movie oh it's a good
movie soldier at one point in the movie
so he's this guy that's been fighting
wars his whole life and they're being
replaced by cybernetic soldiers mmm and
so he gets like sent to a space junkyard
and on the space junkyard there's people
that kind of live there mm-hmm that have
their own little society and he shows up
there and he starts trying to long story
but at one point this woman acts ask him
because he just he just he just is he's
just like a perfect soldier right to the
at one point this woman she says
something along the lines of do you ever
do you ever feel anything and he says I
don't you think I think he says yes sir
he calls everyone sir even they've even
females mm-hmm I think he says something
along the lines of yes sir
fear and discipline yes yes and the
other cool thing about this movie the
movie has like I want to say the first
half an hour
there's no speaking there's no there's
no dialogue they're showing the kids
being selected and trained mm-hm so the
kid that can't keep up with a run they
kill them this is like my dream Society
so I'm gonna go watch this tonight if I
can I guess I will too and she yeah
you're gonna love this book well yeah I
am familiar with it actually so when you
said the sci-fi I was like okay I think
I know it's when you're talking about
the bad kind of kind of marginal special
effects and stuff yeah yeah they need to
remake that movie with me in it hey they
have tattoos I think they have tattoos
either on their armor on their face oh
they have their rank on their face but
then they have tattoos of the like the
bar coders the yeah they have a bar code
but then they have the tattoos of the
campaigns in which they've served so
fear and discipline that's what life is
as a soldier okay you're afraid but
guess what your discipline you overcome
it and according to patent discipline
must be a habit so ingrained that is
stronger than the excitement of battle
or the fear of death and if you think
about just think about that word
excitement right that doesn't only apply
to battle think if you can have enough
discipline that when there's stressful
is occurring around you you have the
discipline to be able to take a step
back and attach instead of getting
wrapped up in it
that's disciplined hmm everyday life he
continues on talking about discipline
the history of our of our invariably
victorious armies demonstrates that we
are the best soldiers in the world this
should make your men proud this should
make you proud
this should imbue your units with
unconquerable self-confidence and pride
in demonstrated ability discipline can
only be obtained when all officers are
so imbued with the sense of their awful
obligation to their men and to their
country that they cannot tolerate
negligence officers who fail to correct
errors or to praise excellence are
valueless in peace and dangerous misfits
in war oh think about that have you ever
heard leadership described as an awful
obligation that is the most exquisite
choice of words that I've heard in a
long time that's what it is an awful
obligation to the men and their country
continues on officers must assert
themselves by example and by voice they
must be preeminent encourage deportment
and dress one of the primary purposes of
discipline is to produce alertness a man
who is so lethargic that he fails to
salute will fall easy victim to an enemy
combat experience has proven that
ceremonies such as formal guard balance
of formal retreat formations and regular
and supervised DREV early formations are
a great help and in some cases essential
to prepare men and officers for battle
to give them that perfect discipline
this
nosov appearance that alertness without
which battles cannot be won so he's all
into that Oh always revelry formation
rev Lee's wake up when we had Joel on
from the French Foreign Legion hmm what
they call a pal
that's revelry and wake up and get in
line and and retreat formal retreat
formation a retreat formation is is
putting down the flag like is the end of
the day hey we're done for the day so
even when you're in garrison you do that
formally right right okay
so there were solely by the way none of
this stuff you never do any of this
stuff in the SEAL Teams yeah like barely
ever when the only time will do is like
if something's gone on we bunch of cute
guys get in trouble all of a sudden
they'll start saying all right we're
gonna be there every morning oh you know
yeah a bunch of misfits so the revelry
formations that's like an official like
a formal wake up payi quints waking up a
6:00
we're meeting at 6:30 that's happening
every day and then at the end of the day
here's what we're doing you know we're
assembling again we're putting out final
word and then you can go and you know
have dinner or whatever huh okay
so just really highly disciplined
formalities yeah even when you're just
waking up it just what the procedure
we're keeping it real across the board
continuing on in the Third Army when
troops are not in the actual combat zone
nor engaged in tactical exercises or
arranged firing core and separate
divisions separate division commanders
will see a that regular revelry
formations be held in attendance at
which there will be a minimum of one
officer per company or similar unit and
in addition when practicable a minimum
of one field officer per regiment or
separate battalion be then it shall be
customary for all organizations to hold
formal retreat under arms attendance in
addition to the prescribed enlisted men
shall be all officers of company grade
in the case of regiments and separate
battalions a minimum of one field
officer be that in the case where music
is available and it is practical from a
billeting standpoint frequent regimental
and battalion retreat parades and
similar ceremonies will be held again
this is stuff that in the SEAL Teams
this never happens mmm I mean it happens
like when someone retires or when
there's a funeral like it does not
happen where you could go you could go
you could go years without ever putting
on a dress uniform if you could go years
so just kind of saying that unit and
organizational guard shall be performed
performed strictly with in accordance to
FM 26 TAC 5 when music is available
formal guard mounts will be held
frequently II that officers in formation
wear a uniform
an agonist to that worn by the enlisted
men and that all officers participate in
all drills and marches at all times with
their organizations or units this
includes marching to and from training
areas and ranges so that's what II
that's that's the end of that list so
you can say he ain't playing around but
you're gonna be highly disciplined
part of this situation here so in life
you know cuz there's like format you
know like dinnertime forgettable that's
like another yeah I mean that's not
another but like an example of life it
is format formality can hey hey fam it's
dinner don't wash hands every day 6
o'clock 555 wash hands
6 o'clock at the table you know were you
home before dinner be home before dinner
all those things there's like things
that you could put your life or you know
wake up when the alarm clock goes off
get your work out look there's things
you do every day right brush your teeth
floss your teeth
stupid right until you got your teeth
falling out yeah well you got dental
problems
difficult bedtime - well the dinnertime
is a big one because it's like everyone
does it there's a procedure that's in
place hey wash hands sometimes they have
one kid set the table or whatever maybe
two kids whatever then you can't just
roll out you got a what nightmares for
you yeah and then it's like okay then
you know then cleanup time or whatever
however you handle that there's
different ways or whatever thing you're
sort of done you know and it's
everybody's a part of that
yeah that's what that's a little minor
example of this yeah that a good end to
it yes thanks continues on here officers
are always on duty and their duty
extends to every individual junior to
themselves in the US Army not only to
members of their organization that's
awesome you know and this is you want to
talk about like this is a good way to
think about life as a human being right
like your duty extends to every human
but I'm here to help other people
hmm not just people that I know but
everybody next Americans with arms and
their hands are fools as well as cowards
to surrender if they fight on they will
conquer he says this cases of
misbehavior before the enemy will be
brought before general court-martial and
tried under the 75th article of war it
has been my experience that many court
marshals are prone to view this most
heinous offense for which the punishment
of death may be inflicted in too lenient
a manner they should realize that the
lives of troops are saved by punishment
of initial offenders cowardice is a
disease and it must be checked before it
becomes an epidemic that sounds super
hardcore I'm gonna tell you a quick
story I was honey were you know it was
Andy and I were training the other day
and we were training on like the Jocko
mat right we're training on the jock on
that and actually as we showed up
someone else was showing up to Train too
and it was two adult males and they had
a fourteen-year-old kid with him
estimated age ners I know the dads a
little bit you know hey what's going on
oh but I bring my friend oh they have
their son or he's got his son here he
trained a little bit here there I'm like
okay but you see he's not sure about
getting back into I guess he probably
trained when he was let's say eight
right so it's been a few years and the
kids are like so and he I look over the
balcony thing and I see the kid I goes
at him and he's like he's like yeah is
he loud and I go yeah I go hey send that
kid up here so the kid comes up
and I'm just like hanging out having fun
whatever so then the kid shows up and
like getting warmed up with Andy and
will take you know five-minute warm-up
round and I say the kid I'm like oh hey
you know you trained before and he says
yeah I changed a little bit I was like
okay cool
you know that's awesome and then I do a
couple rounds with Andy and then I say
and then meanwhile the two dads are
training mm-hmm with geek by the way
this is a long story
sorry I'll make it as short as possible
eventually I say to the kid hey are you
gonna train and he goes well I'm not
sure I'm allowed to mmm and I said no no
actually I own the gym so that means you
can go yeah I'm telling you right now
you can go train so come out on the map
cuz I'm thinking there's a kid here that
could change his life and have a better
life and but there's a whole world will
improve if you transfer good sir
right he's in the gym probably this is
like a low-hanging fruit let's get this
kid in the game so then he says I don't
have a gig want the other the dad not
his dad the other guy the friend of his
dad was like I have one for you and I go
go get it mmm-hmm
so then he runs out goes get the key for
the car the kid kind of puts the Gion
comes out of the mat you can see the
kids not not really hundred percent down
with this whole thing right for whatever
reason right
maybe it's because you know it's weird
to be with your dad and his old man
friend right like I'm a fifty 14 year
old kid who we hang out with these old
guys doing whatever does weird you know
thing is mmm-hmm
here's the apex of the story that I've
been trying to get to eventually the
kids on the mat he's in his ghee I'm
training with Andy we're on a break
during rounds and I hear the kid
it's a fare on a break too because
they're doing five-minute rounds but
it's just the two dads and I hear them
trying to convince the kid to you know
get around with his dad was was the
beginner the other guy is like maybe
high level white belt maybe like blue
belt type level so he's kind of showing
him what to do and they're kind of
trying to convince the kid but the kids
kind of like well
and so I look over there and I go hey
you get on him right now you're doing
the next round and the kid just like
goes and starts the round get on you
know I go ahead you're in I go you go
against him now and make it like just
obeyed right right yeah my point in
saying this whole thing is like
sometimes that kind of leadership is
required because all you're trying to do
is push the kid in the right direction
push the soldier in the right direction
push the employee in the right direction
hey get up there on that thing hey just
make that phone call hey just go
confront that guy you know like
sometimes people need a little push
that's all this kid needed was just a
little push and they weren't he wasn't
looking at me like gonna say no I don't
want to and if he would you know who
knows I would have dealt with the
scenario appropriately at least I would
have tried to but sometimes people just
need a little push so this idea and
that's that whole opening speech from
Patton say what you want about it here's
the standard Americans love winners
Americans hate cowards like that's a
that's a gang mentality that you can
start mm-hmm you can start it in a
company you can start a business we
don't you know we don't settle down we
don't settle for that you don't like
whatever it's gonna be
you call that out and that becomes a
part of your culture right so sometimes
when he's talking about this cowardice
thing I mean you hear it all the time
right you hear it well you hear it
within an organization you know you let
a little bit slack a little bit of slack
here that's why when Hackworth makes the
call of you know you say to the the the
enlisted guys say to the officer
hardcore acondo the officers say back no
fucking slack that starts to become the
mentality even though and Hackworth even
says it in the beginning people are go
this go gung-ho mr. gung-ho it's like no
that starts to become the standard you
have to start somewhere so
these are methods of leadership the
prime can people go overboard the stuff
of course they can totally that's why
there's an economy leadership that has
to be balanced and there's so many times
where patent again kind of like we'd see
with chesty puller like chesty puller
this big you know bombastic figure of
courage and and and and bravery and and
being super hardcore hard-nosed you know
when you read that book about him man he
loved those he loved his guys hey old
man you might not want to do that
remember that like way he would talk to
these guys yeah and yet he was super
hardcore Pat and same thing so he's
saying look when you get cowardice yes
you you you nip it in the bud hmm give
someone acting up you go hey we don't
act like that it's a little gauche next
section is tactical usages these are
good combat principles there is no
approved solution to any tactical
situation boom there is no approved
solution to any tactical situation there
is only one tactical principle which is
not subject to change it is to so use
the means at hand to inflict the maximum
amount of wounds death and destruction
on the enemy in the minimum amount of
time that's what doesn't change too so
use the means at hand to inflict the
maximum amount of wounds death and
destruction on the enemy in the minimum
amount of time that's not gonna change
we're hold or hold fast that one next in
battle casualties very directly with the
time you were exposed to effective fire
your own fire reduces the effectiveness
and volume of the enemy fire while
rapidity of attack shortens the time of
exposure a pint of sweat will save a
gallon of blood that's cover move by the
way obviously we're gonna put down fire
while we move that's covered move
battles are won by fighting the enemy
fear is induced by inflicting death and
wounds on him death and wounds are
produced by fire fire from the rear
more deadly and three times more
effective from fire than fire from the
front but to get fire behind the enemy
you must hold him by frontal fire and
move rapidly around his flank frontal
frontal attacks against prepared
positions should be avoided as possible
if possible cover move and don't attack
the you know directly using direct
attacks thank you thank you
General Patton catch the enemy by the
nose with fire and kick him in the pants
with fire and placed through movement
cover and move hit hard soon that is
with two but two battalions up in a
regiment or two divisions up at a core
or two cores up in an army the idea
being to develop your maximum force at
once before the enemy can develop is as
prioritize and execute by the way focus
your attacks you can never be too strong
get every man in every gun you can
secure provided it does not unduly delay
your attack the German is a champion
digger the larger the force and the more
violence you use in your attack whether
it be men tanks ammunition the smaller
your proportional losses this is a tough
one is the one that you you can get
caught thinking that oh we're gonna do
this big attack that there's gonna be
casualties it's like there's gonna be
less casualties if you do it with the
biggest of course you can and the most
of violence you can possibly do your
attack with never yield ground it is
cheaper to hold what you have then
retake what you have lost never move
troops to the rear for arrest or to
reform at night and in the daytime only
were absolutely necessary such moves may
produce a panic
here's tactical rules in particular
subjects use roads to march on fields to
fight and troops should not deploy into
line until they're forced by enemy fire
when you are advancing in broken country
against possible tank attacks and using
leap and using leapfrog method be sure
to keep the anti guns up as well
leapfrog what you know what that is mmm
I know what the game leapfrog but it's
also cover move what because I hold
position you leap forward once you get
there you hold position meaning you
either fire or you prepared to fire if
you have to and then I move this it's
called a leapfrog in Mountain Country
secure the heights enforcing a pass
secure the heights first this is an
interesting one the effects of Mines is
largely mental not over 10 percent of
our casualties come from them then this
is what what's interesting about that is
that yeah it's like it's largely mental
because you have fear of this thing that
you can't see but he's saying not 10% of
our casualties come from come from them
but for for my generation it's like 70%
of casualties are from IEDs right so a
little different than just mental never
permit a unit's dig in until the final
objective is reached then dig in wire
and mine take plenty of time to set up
an attack it takes at least this here's
why I forget it takes at least two hours
to prepare an infantry battalion to
execute a properly coordinated attack
shoving them into soon produces useless
what's funny about this is nowadays we
will take two weeks to prepare for an
attack so he's saying look hey you need
two hours and the thing is he's right if
everybody knows their jobs you put
together a simple clear plan that's
flexible you don't need all this time
in battle small forces platoons
companies and even battalions can do one
of three things go forward halt or run
think about life think about what you
can do in life you can go forward halt
or run mm-hmm what else is there go
forward halt or run he continues if they
halt or run they will be an even easier
target therefore they must go forward
when caught under fire particularly of
artillery advance out of it never
retreat from it artillery very seldom
shortens its range so think about that
how often are we in a position where we
can go forward we can hold or we can run
and what do you say if you're getting
attacked instead of going backwards go
forwards hmm
general training again skipping a bunch
of sections but general training more
emphasis will be placed on the hardening
of men and officers all soldiers and
officers should be able to run a mile
with combat pack in ten minutes in march
eight miles in two hours when soldiers
are in actual contact with the enemy it
is almost impossible to maintain
physical condition but if the physical
condition is right before they gain
contact it will not fall off
sufficiently during contact to be
detrimental hardening of men and
officers that's just that's what we're
doing just hardly doesn't sound very
comfortable by the way it is not it's
not meant to be our ability to fight at
night as opposed to move into position
at night for a dawn attack is pibbly bad
we must learn to execute the attack in
the dark this might be one of my
favorites
sharpen axes pickaxes and shovels now
and keep them sharp just think about
that sharpen your shovels
I've never sharpened a shovel in my life
I'm going to go home today and sharpen
my shot
you know those animals that's a mindset
yeah never mind sharpen your sword look
you're short better be sharp I'm gonna
sharpen my damn shovel yeah in the event
of just get ready be ready yeah
stay ready stay ready I might have to
hit you in the head with a pickaxe and I
wanted to go clean through or dig a hole
real quick or dig a hole either way I'm
gonna be ready yeah battles are fought
by platoons and squads place emphasis on
small unit combat instructions so that
is conducted with the same precision as
close order drill a good solution
applied with vigor now is better than a
perfect solution 10 minutes later
instruction from the squad to the
regiment's and tables should be used and
the officer or non-comp being instructed
should give the actual orders he will
give in combat sand tables need not be
complicated a piece of ground in the Lee
of a building is just as good and much
simpler I used to have this little kit I
learned this from one of the Australian
SAS guys that was stationed with us over
at SEAL team one and as you know the
secrets boxes sucrets I think it's
called breath mints yeah yeah yeah it's
like a little tin box yeah so in this
little tin box you can open it up and I
had little little like little wood
little wood things little wood placards
and they had each little wood placard
was shaped kind of like a teardrop okay
so is you picture a teardrop yeah and
then on the teardrop it said Pete II was
the first one and the next one said PL
the next one said RTO so this point man
platoon leader
radio man and so I had one of these
little teardrops for each guy in the
platoon and then they I had like a few
pieces of ribbon in there okay and the
ribbon is used to go oh here's a road
here's a stream okay here's a fence okay
so what you could do is you could sit
down in a perimeter and you could make a
little Santa
the sand table let's talk about it's a
little diagram of what's happening and
so I had these little I think I had like
a couple like a little tiny house like a
monopoly monopoly houses so yeah there's
a building here and there's a building
here where to be moving here yeah that's
what I had and so you'd be able to break
this thing out you'd seem like a real
pro little else we're out they can't
even know what a placard technically is
but but you described it pretty good
what it's just a small tear drop
representative of the yes person and
their versa now the reason you have a
tear drop there's not a tear drop is
because then whatever point the tear the
the thing was pointed out weapons was
faced oh okay yeah good
dang in the monopoly house is it was it
a house or condo because they're
different the house is a little green
when they come to have a grizzle and
read looks a little bit more tactical
and those were only because you couldn't
actually show but you can show how
you're gonna set that would be like the
target so now we see how we're gonna set
up like targets here boom you guys are
going here here's we're gonna maneuver
and then cuz its way but it's just nice
imagine you're in the field and you got
a draw in the dirt right but you don't
you finding rocks and you're like no
this is you arty oh and he's like which
one is me great all those problems are
solved yeah great help us a crap box
show them what's up even it's good yeah
they do that online a movie for sure
what the secret but that particular one
by saying to create a diagram of the
plan you know and it's like a rod
sometimes a rock depending on the movie
obviously I come back to the future yeah
up what's his name Doc Brown whatever he
made the this he's like please excuse
the crude mock-up you know I didn't have
the time to scale an Athena body
everything he would go to like these
briefings battalion belief briefings or
Brigade briefings they would have they
had massive sand tables you'd walk
around on him Oh like all the roads were
laid out you know the a road would be
four inches wide you know six inches
wide and all the buildings built out of
blocks yeah out of just 2x4 so he's some
surprise it's something is it there
Kasana up two by fours glued together
having a good old time but you get the
thing is once again in comparison to the
thing that you just look at on a
PowerPoint used
walking around that visual actual model
you get a better understanding of it yes
you know fully yeah so get yourself a
little scrap box altar like a whole
place probably it seems probably maybe I
can make one and like show it to people
I don't think I could find I used to
have I can't find it anymore what the
sucrets this you know the whole little
kit that I used to have a metal fine you
made that kit you know made it's not
like yeah I made it maybe I need to make
one that I could offer to people right
people everywhere that are waiting they
need sir just to randomly have or what
like alright yeah I think that's the DIY
situation yeah it's put on yourself I'm
not gonna make them decisions been made
yeah kind of want to go it is cool
because that's the kind of stuff you do
when you're a little kid let's figure
out what's awesome about being in the
SEAL Teams or in the military is like
all the things that you did when you
were a little kid you're actually doing
for real and it's the best yeah and it's
like real yeah yeah I'm like all I'm
really doing this yeah I really did that
a real mission you know I really like I
really sat and briefed my guys on like
killing people you know it's you sit
there you think back like what well
that's what I was doing yeah yeah oh
yeah I did that I gave that brief you
know it's like it's so lucky to be in to
be in a situation where you get to grow
up and do what you wanted to do
I didn't even grow up yeah alright
guides Oh officers men must know their
equipment they must train with the
equipment they intend to use in battle
equipment must be the best operational
condition when taken to the theater of
operations yeah you you have to use what
you're gonna use you have to guides for
officers officers must possess
self-confidence and confidence of their
men and the confidence of their men two
of the best ways of producing this is
meticulously conducted close order drill
conducted by officers and platoon
marches of 48 to 60 hours during which
the platoon is wholly on its own
check in the first actions new troops
must receive aggressive leadership by
all grades including general officers
who must be seen in the front in the
some in the frontline during action
check there is a universal failure to
repeat back oral orders this failure is
certain to result in grave errors
messages and orders must use concise
military verbage so that's the second
time he's hitting on this makes you
start to think doesn't it maybe he's
onto something
mm-hmm when you tell somebody to do
something have them tell it back to you
hmm
make it simple clear and concise
prisoners German prisoners over 40 talk
more easily than the younger ones they
must be examined separately and not
returned to cages where the young ones
are prisoners and other Germans usually
talk all prisoners other than Germans
usually talk freely and inaccurately
they too should be examined out of
hearing and later separated from the
young Nazis yeah you can a man I mean
just like we read in the unit it's not
unit 731 Oh ordinary men in the police
battalion that the older Nazis like they
they weren't convinced you can imagine
you when you capture them they're like
I'll tell you what's going on you you
capture a young militant you know 15
year old Nazi Hitler Youth he's not
gonna say anything to you he's gonna say
blood and honor that's it yeah there is
a tendency for the chain of command to
overload junior up there is a tendency
for the chain of command to overload
junior officers with excessive
requirements in the way of training and
reports you will leave Li you will
alleviate this burden by eliminating
non-essential demands boom there you go
everybody should listen to that part of
it you know how you get in situations
where you be your basic attitude well is
it well it sucked for me I had to go
through it now I'm going to make you go
through it - yeah that's what I think
some of this is because that some of us
because people lose memory of what it
was like yeah and so they they start
they just carry on a tradition some of
its I go I do those reports when I was a
new guy no you're gonna do them - yeah I
wonder and what do you think about that
we're okay I'm not okay there's kind of
two parts there's the part where it's
like okay there is some valuable things
that a new guy has to go through let's
see like a hazing or a blah blah blah
but it actually serves the actual
process right and then there's that
additional like oh that's the tradition
as a new guy you gotta I don't know pay
your dues for like do you think there's
value in that for like there's there's
some value there is definitely some
value and and also you know when and
Lafe and I talk about this all time when
we got told to do paperwork and Lafe and
Seth didn't want to do paperwork and
they're like do you Jocko can you put a
stop at this and I'm like no actually we
do the paperwork mm-hmm that doesn't
mean that I said oh I like doing the
paperwork and I think it's beneficial no
I was trying to build a relationship
with my boss as often as I could
especially overseas I tried to eliminate
as much paperwork as possible wasn't
always successful but I tried mm-hmm
yeah and there is a you know when I went
to Officer Candidate School there was
all kinds of things that seemed really
dumb when you're there especially I went
there and I've been in the Navy for
eight years so I kind of understood what
was happening but those people that have
just been in the Navy for ten weeks when
the drill instructor finally said hey
this is this is why we do this to you
hmm
and everything kind of makes sense so
there's definitely something you know
I'm not looking at your meal while
you're eating it right what does that do
develops your peripheral vision yelling
everything that you say what does that
do it allows you to speak with more
confidence yeah a lot it makes you learn
how to think before you speak
mmm think about every time you talk you
have to yell at the top of your lungs
that should you have to do it off to
Canada school every single time you talk
the entire time you're there you have to
yell at the top of your lungs so anyone
that's shy is gonna get over it anyway
that's like like uncomfortable high - I
had a professor when I went to college
and when she spoke and covered her mouth
yeah but every time she spoke she
averred her mouth because she just
didn't want to talk and she was a
professor yeah you know so she needs to
go to OCS and yell at the top of her
lungs for 13 weeks she walked out of
there going hand away from mouth talking
coffee teaching the class yeah let's do
it
yeah that's assumed that's pretty common
I don't like to yell you know when
they're like hey like you actually yell
and whatever yeah I don't really like to
do it yeah okay get you a billet at OCS
13 weeks of yelling you know maybe get
that voice adjusted a little bit jack
section here on infantry infantry must
move in order to close with the enemy
it must shoot in order to move convert
move I need to make this stuff up man
it's so interesting when people you know
say oh I don't know about that techno
cover move is a real thing it's
undeniable yeah undeniable when physical
targets are not visible the fire of all
infantry weapons must search the area
probably occupied by the enemy I
remember when I learned that for the
first time I remember all I think was
actually I think he might have been
Roger Hayden that was like no shoot
where you think the enemy would be hmm I
was like oh because if you think where
they could be I mean when you're getting
fired at from a certain area you look to
that area you can't tell exactly where
the enemy is so you shoot in the five
most likely places that you see there
and everyone else in your platoon or
task unit is doing the same thing you're
gonna be shooting at the bad guys like
somewhere mm-hmm
it reduces and when you're doing that it
reduces the accuracy of his fire and
increases our confidence shoot short
this is another thing we learn at all
time ricochets make nastier sounds and
wounds do you understand that so when
you're shooting at a bad guy shoot low
who said someone who's seen that Roger
heat we all see has probably Roger it
walking it in with a machine gun yes it
can do the ricochets are flying on
ricochets that means the bullets
tumbling when it hits you it's a
nightmare
yes don't any or if you shoot high it
doesn't hit anything that's right that's
right
so shoot short ricochets make nastier
sounds and wounds to halt under fire is
folly to halt under fire and not fire
back is suicide
move forward out of fire officers must
set the example
next well skip a few sections here few
men are killed by the bayonet many are
scared of it
bayonets should be fixed when the fire
fight starts
bayonets must be sharpened by the
individual soldier the German hates the
bayonet and is inferior to our men with
it our men should know this that is
psychological warfare like what he's
actually doing sure bayonets are sorry
but what he's actually saying there he's
saying that you know you have to sharpen
your own band that think about the
psychological beauty of that scenario
yep yeah and then you think the German
hey does Patton know the German
individual soldier doesn't know that but
you know what I'm gonna tell my frickin
entire Third Army that the German hates
the band that they're scared of it and
makes sense and we're better at it than
they are and even starts this whole
thing a few people are even killed with
a knife it doesn't matter they're scared
of it sharpen it
we're better than them with the bayonet
it makes sense like if you see even a
picture of a god but let's say like a
guy some crazy guy your enemy he's mad
he wants to kill you and he has a gun
you're like okay he has a gun we all
have guns all good but if the guy has a
psychotic blade on the front of his gun
and he's like sharpening it himself
like brah I'm not going near that guy
he's like that knife makes him seem
crazy there is something very zen and
beautiful about sharpening your knife -
yeah like it's a it's a soul cleansing
tasks yes sir sharpening your knives and
you know now I'm adding to that
sharpening your shovel next the m1 rifle
is the most deadly rifle in the world if
you cannot see the enemy you can at
least shoot at the place where he's apt
to be same message there you've got
something in here I might not have
outlined it but just he basically you
know these things that he's saying he
knows that he's saying them for the site
psychological boost for his troops hmm
he says here the defence will consist of
mutually supporting small groups
arranged in depth and completely wired
in he didn't say overlapping fields of
fire but he should have mines holy place
talks about artillery talks about armor
talks about recon talks about
anti-aircraft and anti-tank sand and
look all those things are brilliant and
I'm not breezing through them because I
don't love artillery and I don't love
armor anybody that knows anything about
me knows that I love armor and artillery
but he's the sections in this are very
very tactical he talks about maintenance
weapons will be kept in perfect order
preventive maintenance will be enforced
particular attention should be given to
tire pressure lubrication battery
voltage and water in radiators vehicles
will be serviced and made operational
before their crews rest vehicles will be
marked in accordance with paragraph six
TAC 14 a are 850 TAC 5 we were we did a
long long mission like a whole cycle of
darkness my first appointment and we got
back to base and everyone was beat and
my leading petty officer wasn't he was
the lead nav and the lead nav guy is the
kind of guy that directs the convoy then
we drove but we got back to the gate and
Baghdad on an off base at Baghdad and
he's like he comes up on the radio and
he's like hey boss can we just take the
vehicles back and refuel you know later
and I'd let it sit right there like that
say anything then I finally go- take it
to the fuel depot and he's like right
when i jammed up the rhythm he already
knew the answer and he was like and I
let everybody I let everybody cuz we're
exhausted it's been and it was freezing
cold it was freezing cold it was raining
so it's raining like so the and this is
before we had doors we didn't have doors
on our Humvees so it's probably 35 or 40
degrees because there was a little bit
of sleet happening so I was right around
the freezing mark and we did probably a
four-hour drive to get to the target
area the target was outside it took us a
few hours to get this whole thing
settled we ended up with a giant we
ended up having to move around the giant
cache of weapons that we captured
outside in the rain Baba bong and we get
in the vehicles and so you're the
vehicles it's 35 to 40 degrees it's
raining and you've got a 50 mile an hour
wind the entire time because their doors
door so everyone's freezing when we get
back the sun's coming up so it's been an
entire cycle of darkness so I don't know
how many hours was something like no
there's no sleep yeah and LPO comes over
the radio he's like hey boss can we just
take it back to a camp and fuel up
vehicles later I'm like negative what
stick to a few people wait where was
this Baghdad Dan gets that cold huh yeah
huh middle of winter cold especially
with that 60 mile an hour wind so there
you go that's the deal that's the deal
you take care you take care of that team
gear because I guarantee you that one
time you decide you're gonna not fuel up
the vehicles that's the time you're
gonna call down at a QRF and we would
get called out on cue refs pretty
regularly not all the time but I mean it
was no
he was a high it was a decent percentage
not a high percentage mere there's a
decent percentage that we get to call
them said hey we need QRF out here we
need QRF over there that cool let's cool
you need quick reaction force meaning
troops are in trouble hold on while we
refuel our vehicles no no we're never
gonna do that and the stunt doesn't
mention the precedent right we're you
know and this goes for anything or
whatever I know it's very prevalent with
kids where you know they they want to
push up against the rule not in some you
know hostile way or whatever just sort
of like yeah like you know like I don't
know no desert during the week or
something like this and then it's like a
week come on no not happening
we're not doing it desert that one day
it's kind of like ooh they know like oh
sure that's the rule but under certain
emotional circumstances can get away the
cool figure I mean and you know II hey
you know what LPL is looking out for the
boys yeah which is part of the job right
there's part of there's a push-pull
right there's always that push-pull he's
looking out for the boys he knows their
time hey look even if we got called for
QRF we're not super effective because
we've been up for 2030 hours right yeah
so we're not super effective and he's
probably thinking about that too yeah
yeah that's actually a good point he he
would technically have like a little
argument yes an argument it was like hey
we're like less effective Andres is
employed as fat and said so hey man so
yeah make sense but but we had to hold
the line on that one yeah that makes him
the QRF situation makes it worse yeah
QRF situation is important and well
you'd rather the guys be a little bit
more tired than the the vehicles beat on
empty that was a good moment of silence
on that one the other good moment sounds
we got this is again my first deployment
to Iraq and we got we got ambushed in a
convoy and pretty tip cause in the
number-two vehicle pretty typical that
the enemy wouldn't realize where we were
because we were driving really fast
blacked out
they wouldn't realize until towards the
end of the convoy and so in this
particular one we got ambushed
and it was mostly centered on the back
vehicles right but I was looking you
know as I'm looking at my field of fire
you know I can see all kinds of tracers
going by I can see and then they fired a
couple RPGs that went over our convoy
and exploded on my side of the road say
they ambushed us from the other side so
this big ambush happens and you know the
call comes out which actually the call
is made by the same guy that was asking
a question earlier it's the LPO who's
lead nav and you know he just pushed
through push through which is totally
normal so we did it and then we just
keep going right and I don't say
anything and and then my platoon chief
again both my Bell p.m. to achieve
awesome guys yeah we always had a good
time but he comes up with the radio you
can hear and his voice is a little bit a
little bit spun up you know mm-hmm and
he's like hey Jocko you got ambushed
back here and I just like logged over to
silence and I said Roger that was it we
did what we had to do but those are
funny moments of silence that happened
from time to time because everyone's
kind of because because in my platoons
and my tasks you know talking on the
radio was so limited mm-hmm like no
basically no one talked on the radio you
know unless you had something really
important to say mm-hmm and so when
there was something on the radio
everyone was 100% listening and when
someone was asking me a question
everyone was 1,000% listening to what my
responsibiiity when it's like hey we
might get some more sleep or hey we just
got ambushed does Jocko know it's like
both those people are going what are we
gonna do because there's a possibility
it's like hey I'll stop we're gonna turn
around and go and hunt down these people
that ambushed us which is not a good
idea and we didn't do it but you know
everyone's thinking maybe I'm gonna say
that or maybe honest or whatever but
everyone's listening to what my response
in here you little moment of silence
dramatic effect possibly or I'm just
actually here's what's actually
happening I'm sitting there considering
the situation you know okay is everyone
okay
they must be you know casually report or
hey maybe we should go to sleep before
I'm thinking through the actual
situation I'm not just you know trying
to be a jerk trying to be cool trying to
be cool I'm actually thinking okay I
know we got ambushed I'm waiting for is
there's casualty I think you know I -
isn't like are we up or no if the
push-through call comes everyone calls
calls vehicles up the front from the six
is up five is up four is up three is ups
already know everyone's good we're
already good you know jack alright this
last section is called care of men which
once again you know you look at the you
look at the leadership strategy and
tactics manual and some of the most
important things I try and make as clear
as possible is that you gotta you gotta
care about your man get a care about
your people that's what you gotta do
it's what Mookie Yama taught me I mean I
wouldn't say Mookie Yama taught me that
but when he said it I was like that's
the underpinning of everything you know
this thing that's been a a tenet of my
leadership principles hey let's call it
a let's call it a a sort of a flying
below the radar tenant you know like oh
yeah I could take care of people yeah I
totally get that but when I heard Mookie
Yama general Mookie Amma talked about it
and we talked about Hackworth and just I
was like oh yeah it's not just it's not
just under the radar it's the real thing
yeah so hence General Patton he's got an
entire section called care of men
officers are responsible not only for
the conduct of their men in battle but
also for their health and contentment
when not fighting and officer must be
the last man to take shelter from fire
and first to move forward similarly he
must be the last man to look after his
own comfort at the close of a March
he must see that his men are cared for
the officer must constantly interest
himself in the rations of men he should
know his men so well that any sign of
sickness or nervous strain will be
apparent to him and he can take such
action as may be necessary again why is
he talking about this this is Patton
this is a known they show in the movie
the big scene where he slaps around the
guy as a coward and all that stuff kid I
get this guy out of this ward
he had this reputation that he's like
abusive freakin care about your men and
think about what he's saying here like
the last the the last guy to move
recover the last guy to take care of
himself after a March the rations go to
the men first everything is about the
troops that's what a leader is continue
he must look after his men's feet see
that they have properly fitting shoes
and good condition at that their socks
fit loose or tight socks make sore feet
he must anticipate change of weather and
see the proper clothing and foot gear is
asked for and obtained so that's that's
what that's the last thing that he talks
about is caring for your men the
successful soldier wins battles cheaply
so far as his own casualties are
concerned but he must remember that
violent attacks although costly at the
time save lives in the end so yes that
once it was the same message he's been
giving violence although it seems like
it's going to increase casualties if you
attack violently it will save lives in
the end and that and that right there is
the best way that you can care for your
people have them ready have them trained
have them disciplined and then go on the
attack then this thing is signed GS
Patton jr. Lieutenant General US Army
commanding
so awesome information from Patton once
again and I got I've got some more we
may even roll right into I've got some
more patent stuff to talk about you know
because there are some things that
people freak out about is very
flamboyant right sure let's face it
that's not really my style right
flamboyance not really my thing right so
he's got some things that we are gonna
need to talk about then we will perhaps
we'll do it next time but eventually
we'll get to it so Patton don't throw
the baby out with the bathwater if you
don't like that those parts of him
because believe me as flamboyant as this
guy was he was about discipline he was
about taking care of his people and we
can all learn a lot we can also talk
about the fact that you know he
sometimes didn't play the game and he
didn't get the positions he wanted to
probably oftentimes because he didn't
play the game so we can talk about all
that stuff for now we're gonna hold what
we got just did some live gigs and I've
done DC New York austin la everything
sold out Seattle and San Francisco still
come but they're both already sold out
but anyways it's been awesome it's been
an incredible experience and meeting
everyone and I can't miss isn't to ask
you to come because they're already done
but I just wanted to say to everyone
that came doubt to him thank you for
coming to them they were incredible to
be a part of so and I will schedule some
more of them and maybe echo will come I
don't know maybe are you gonna come to
Seattle
Oh San Francisco San Francisco okay cool
sold out so if someone was just kind of
waiting to hear if you were gonna be
there late yeah awesome you know with
that deco Charles we are trying to be
you know we're taking advice from
General Patton we're trying to be more
disciplined we're trying to be more
courageous in we're trying to be
physically hardened hardened we're
trying to be better what do you know of
that can perhaps help us in all those
arenas that gives aside from sharpening
our shovel sandy can all right we're
gonna do jujitsu train today you didn't
I did yeah did it you you were
preoccupied in various things
I was actually preparing for this
podcast which which is what I have to do
yeah well I prepared for no no no I
pressed record which is great it's more
of a mental preparation but you know
nonetheless I feel good about that
how'd you feel okay be honest were you
like my goal was I did not make my goal
my goal was to be prepped by noon coming
here train shower record that's that was
the plan I did not accomplish my mission
so I had to prioritize and execute we
owe this podcast to our people yes we
will not prioritize my personal agenda
of training above taking care of the
troops the troops expect a podcast yes
on Wednesday Tuesday night even yes we
must deliver that means I have work to
do I know it doesn't mean anything news
I know it doesn't even fear with any
part of your personal life any part of
your personal side but I have work to do
it does it's just more psychological
okay well you keep telling yourself that
all that are great
of course and you know I only say that
because when you came in at the tail end
of joining you know you're ready to you
know believe hard and you're prepped and
you're good even the way he made me look
you looked at me in a way that I was
like okay cool I could have a change
right now is that what you just said was
written all over your face like you came
in there was some you know there are
some people here you know boom Jacko's
know you know here taking some pictures
or whatever and meanwhile I'm with and
you see me and I seen your face like oh
man you're training like your left you
know and here's the actual funny but I'm
just remembering that part the funny
part is when you walked out on the mat
you took off your shoes you walk kind of
man and when you walk up on the mat I
think this is just kind of in all of us
anyway so we're you sort of like you
feel like for LA chromatic term the
energy of the man or you know so that's
why it feels weird if you if you have
your regular clothes on and you walk out
on the mat you're like bright you feel
weird it's not it's not jamming or it's
not vibing together you know so you
walked out on the man kind of like you
were kind of warming up for so I know
cuz think of how many thousands and
thousands and thousands of times when I
take off my flip-flops my slippers when
we used to call him in Hawaii I take off
my slippers and go on the mat it's like
that means something yeah that's like
it's like what I used to put down my
nods on my you know on my helmet right
put it down your nods all of a sudden
it's like okay it's on you la commode
you up you like okay so you lock and
load your weapon all the time you get do
it in your yeah oh you're like okay cool
you know this is it yeah so I walk out
on the mat take off my take off my
slippers and walk out on the mat he felt
a little and and you know it's like yeah
and I see you kind of just giving off a
vibe right when I think because you were
you were literally pacing oh here's the
thing we weren't being hostile making
jokes like that kind wasn't agree we're
sure it wasn't that we were talking
about something like fur like
legitimately normal but you were pacing
out there oh my god I wanted a secret
and that pissed me off amen that's life
actually let's go okay so jujitsu that's
one of the many good things about you -
and I mentioned this before where it's
like so good exercise so good mentally
physically like all this stuff it's
literally fun yeah it's like yeah like
if you come in and this goes for me even
if I'm like there just to record
whatever and not to Train furrow like
I'm here for a specific reason not to
Train or whatever and I come and I see
people training or whatever I literally
feel like I'm missing out like I'm
missing that you know how like when your
friends go hang out and go do something
and you gotta stay home and like yeah it
felt like you felt that you kind of
missed out I did I say my brother it's
all good but this to me this far comes
very good so I'm kind of glad you did
and the good news about it is you just
is gonna be here there's gonna be up
tomorrow it's gonna be here you never
get this day back or training yeah that
might have been a little something yeah
may think red alert or maybe next time
give me a little something
it's all part of the team helps downs
every single almost sounded like a
threat not to make the trade right now
cuz we will do it not a threat you know
I'm just saying that's that's how it
goes sometimes it a little something
I meant learning was good you know
nonetheless
hey it will be here and actually which
kind of lends support to the point that
hey not everyone is doing jujitsu right
now but guess what this should be if you
go tomorrow it'll be it'll be there if
you walk in tomorrow yeah and also if
you walk in and it's your first day you
don't know anything about it there's
other people everyone on that mat has
been there there's nothing to be
embarrassed about you get go get on the
mat and if chance is all right that's a
good point right there because chances
are more people are gonna be like new
people yes in advance for sure probably
what would you say would be the average
if you go on any random and it granted a
lot of times they have a beginners class
which is even bigger percentage yeah new
people I think it's a bell curve yeah
it's like half right well a bell curve
bottom 10% like they don't know anything
or they look bottom 10% three months or
less of training the middle is whatever
anywhere between three months and five
years and then there's like the top 10%
have been training for
actually at our school is a lot more
than yeah that we are a little heavy on
the top end we're having on the bottom
end too no yeah baby
no no you're our school is so big and
like you know that it's the key part
there's no key then it's like we're you
know like the advanced guys like when I
get on the mat there's most there's so
many people that have 5 years 8 years 10
years it's a lot of people that's true
but there's a bunch of people too that
just started right you know what it
could be and then again I'm over here
just researching it right now in my head
we're good that's not really no no no I
just think when you go to the Met and
you see all our advance guys or should I
say all the guys that are here that are
advance Chancellor you know them so
they're like oh man we have a lot of
them you know whatever but meanwhile you
say the same thing about people that I
don't know yeah yeah that's cute because
I don't know I don't know that guy he
must not ever trained before he could be
trained for a year right yeah that's due
to I mean most if someone's training you
for you I know
yeah but it's like yeah different but
yeah yeah I think so but and but then
you have to think about the belt
distribution curve too it's like super
bottom heavy because as you progress up
the belt ranks does either progress yes
exactly right because you progress out
of the belt or out of jiu-jitsu
okay so you mentioned key nogi what does
all that mean anyway I get Aggie ghetto
or GG everybody knows that's the best
ski in the world straight-up factually
you mentioned facts versus opinions is
the fact not an opinion happens to be
made in America along with other stuff
or Jemaine calm yes always we get these
things that are made in America all this
stuff including a a hundred percent made
in America
yes what about where the substances that
they're made of where those things from
what like the cotton that's grown yes so
they can put it through the Loom a
million different moving parts in
aluminum yeah and made into the fabric
that is woven and then constructed into
various items and care including jeez
and including jeans oh yeah
jeans boots boots
t-shirts shirts and rash guards
so these clothing is what worked on
beanies
okay so you can get a lot of clothing
made in America best clothing ever in
the world factually yeah how many genes
have I owned in my life probably okay my
adult life I probably owned let's call
it I'm not a lot there's not a lot of
jeans because I would have jeans for
like eight years right maybe eight years
is long but anyways I'd have jeans for a
while yeah I probably had 20 pairs of
jeans in my adult life now my jeans
origin jeans are the best jeans that
I've ever worn now I can't say I've ever
worn a pair of 640 dollar what are those
called
like skinny dudes no I haven't you own
any those I haven't had any the low rise
boot cut yeah like oh well no I mean
what's the word designer jeans even even
at the height even at the height of
designer jeans which by the way at the
height of all that stuff MMA was totally
wrapped around that stuff all right like
if you were to develop you were to like
find a picture and in 2006 2008 of a
bunch of MMA guys of which you and I
both were there's a high percentage that
50% of the individuals in that picture
would be wearing jeans that had
non-functional aspects and therefore
they would be determined as designer
just and they cost you know several
hundred dollars yeah so even at the
height of that you cannot find pictures
of me in genes that have non-functional
aspects you can only find me in genes
that have functional aspects I believe I
believe that yes
so check you can get
jeans from our job that are functional
functional slightly do that
there's no designer no niner-zero
no no fashion do the old-fashioned it no
no fashion the form follows function so
do they look appropriate absolutely yeah
there you go
do they have spirit yes
do they have soul affirmative well
they're the only jeans that I wear so
you know obviously I'm not doubt oh you
got yourself a bit you milk done or not
not the deltas no just the regular you
know functional oh yeah very good though
nonetheless yes or Jemaine calm you get
all this stuff also supplements gentler
for krill oil these are for your joints
maintain stay in the game for real you
can be super strong you can squat 600
pounds literally if you can squat 600
pounds but your joints are jamming you
up but you're not squatting nothing
maybe you'll do a warm-up set yeah and
then just sort of not squat or whatever
deadlift whatever you doing unless joint
warfare krill oil these are very good
for you joints and they will keep you in
the game discipline and discipline go
I'm not gonna say that I lived off of it
on my last week and a half when I was
getting zero sleep and just having to do
interviews with people well those things
end at what 9 technically but you just
go right cuz you don't like leave oh no
no no that's cool no the the live gigs
for sure but getting interviewed by
whatever different channels and I had to
wake up at 1 o'clock in the morning to
go on
coast to coast am of your listen that
nothing knows do anyways I was up at one
o'clock and went 1 2 3 and then I for
whatever 6:45 I was sitting in a studio
on national TV getting interviewed you
know like so no sleep no food no factor
guess what
discipline go get some you can feel it
but the can you can feel it mix up some
Jaco Palmer
totally good to go get get your a-game
on and it
and take yourself one of the discipline
go pills get that hitter
Molk by the way yeah
Mulk is there well I was like because
I've been you know have the big tub
wooden containers yeah but I have the
packages left over from muster or
whatever do does origin yes sell the
packs okay yeah okay so yeah if you just
prefer ill just want to get her anyway
yeah say I'm okay
extra protein in the form of a dessert
hitter or otherwise theater or full
dessert and don't forget about the water
kid milk as well for the kid it's that
way you don't have to kid your feed your
kid poison unbeknownst to them they
think you're giving them a treat what
you are which you are an evil treat if
it's filled with sugar or you can give
them something that's good for you yeah
the front end that's good
so really you know the deal with the
devil right you know the deal with the
devil
that whole expression okay so I'm like
what does that even mean this you know
what it is it's really kind of simple
and you actually essentially talk about
it it's like basically you do something
for a short term versus the expenses
that the long term the devil wants you
to take the short term scenario yeah
yeah so that's what retreats a lot of
the time for the kids are it's a deal
with the devil it's like oh my gosh
they're so happy with you oh my gosh
they're so you know they're behaving so
well right now
because of the treat and they're so
happy look at their little smiles look
is there little diabetic souls being
saved by sugar no yeah that's the devil
collecting collecting on this deal yeah
so don't do that
junk away to you yes also chuckle white
tea I'm into the cans more than the brew
I've been to both yeah yeah I could see
that mmm-hmm but yeah I'm more into the
kid
thank you by the way right on also
chocolates door it's called Jacko's door
and this is where you can get more
shirts more hoodies beanies rash guards
rash guards oh yeah more representative
of the
directly indeed yeah look at me like you
want me to say something else
no no I'll say yes you're right yeah
well there your statement is improve
there you go even Josh you know it's
funny actually what's funny about you
saying this is when I see someone and
like at the live events of course saw a
lot of people that were we're
representing on the path and I would say
to them you're representing you on the
path yeah
so it's your loyal statement that you
make about representing on the path has
now become part of the lexicon of the
troopers good there you go after Charles
oh good yeah I feel like that sort of
sort of was your contribution pressing
record and saying that the lexicon yeah
what is lexicon like the verbage that
were the words that we use oh all right
boom there you go
and yes it is all week I mean let's face
it man like you see anywhere even at an
event you see somebody representing
you're like you feel a little something
there's a connection there's a
connection yep big time unless jaw
closed or calm if you like something get
something represent men represent I'll
see you in the wild all recognize and if
you like listening to this podcast which
if you don't you're not hearing this
right now so I guess we're just talking
to the people everyone that's listening
that's right now if you don't like the
podcast you're not listening so if you
do subscribe to it yes
is it important to subscribe it's not
not important it's not a throwaway thing
yeah so it's some must be but yeah
nonetheless thinking when you subscribe
to the podcast it's sort of like when
you were a little kid and you got some
new sneakers and it makes you feel a
little bit faster when you actually
click Subscribe you like yeah you know
it's a level of commitment that you're
making to that you know to the path yeah
no it's not hey I feel like it's more of
a symbolic commitment because let's face
it you can just you click unsubscribe
just as easily easily as subscribe you
know in case like if you don't like it
or whatever but you know what
functionally no functionally look if you
live depends on where you listen to it I
get it but functions click Subscribe
goes into your little that little part
where you don't have to do a search now
or nothing like this
and boom you know that's in your it's in
your whole thing it's part of your day
part of your day it's part of your life
so I think I'm actually correct yes and
your initial assessment of my statement
is wrong okay when you subscribe you
take one step further down the path that
is true and don't forget about the
grounded podcast which I'm sure will do
another one and don't forget about the
warrior kid podcast which I will get
some of those done and don't forget
about warrior kid soap Irish Oaks ranch
com
it's a warrior kid who's actually got a
business going young Aiden making soap
so that what week his contribution to
society making soap so that we all can
stay clean also YouTube for the video
version of this podcast a lot of people
watch it make sense in fact you know
sometimes not all the time but sometimes
the video version will come out you know
a half day sometimes even a day later
then the audio some people freak out
about them well where's the YouTube
where is the winds when's it coming out
it's kind like hey that know they say
when's the podcast coming out or either
the podcast be no but and I'm like no
you know what they like they watch it
mm-hm and it makes sense to the Smart
TVs and what not unless we do have a
YouTube channel for this method of
consumption oh Tae Yong tae from origin
yes I do
he him and his friends they like on a
Friday night they'll like put put
YouTube on and just watch the podcast
watch Rogen's podcast whatever like
that's that's what they're doing yeah as
if they're watching UFC but know they're
watching us talk about no patent or
whatever yeah well and it kind of makes
sense when you think about a case so the
content wise okay good
the content is the contents good content
but to sit around and watch like
remember like old school back in the day
I don't know 60 minutes I'm sure it's
still on oh whatever
oh yeah six seaming it special with I
don't know Michael Jordan or what I
don't who ever they have on there and
it's just one person talking to the
other person
asking questions Q&A essentially I guess
pretty much - yeah same thing same thing
except the contents a little bit
different of course so that's a much
better I think it's better yes you know
what I mean yeah because 60 minutes in
even 60 minutes
yeah there's commercials in there and
then there's three stories so you're
actually getting twelve minutes or seven
minutes
look what he could what can you learn
about patents theories of combat in
seven minutes you just learn like maybe
partially one of them maybe maybe maybe
nonetheless ty keep that up and all his
friends hanging with him yeah man keep
that up that's good psychological offer
oh yeah YouTube channels yes we have
YouTube channel that's that was the
point of my whole thing Oh
and people should subscribe to it I say
they should yeah that's okay official it
is the thing that's cause your it
influences what you see on your YouTube
homepage meant which I'm look I have
YouTube read me - oh where are YouTube
premium yeah they called it now it used
to be red I'm in school and look I'm not
trying to I'm not trying to make Google
more money by telling you to get YouTube
red or YouTube premium but it's 9 bucks
a month and you don't have to watch it a
single advertisement on YouTube ever
again oh yeah cuz they'll sneak them in
the middle of the putt castle
I know I saw on YouTube comments on one
of our podcasts someone said I can't
believe you're advertising and I can't
believe the advertisement that popped up
it whatever and I said can't believe you
won't pay nine dollars a month never
never have to watch the advertisement
again
Premium YouTube yeah worth every penny
I'll throw that out there either man you
know me I don't like to spend that extra
money right and but it doesn't make
sense because like okay so I've like a
handful of YouTube channels hmm
and they're not all premium so when I go
to the other channels to do whatever and
then I'd like whatever forget to sign
jockey and remember and then the
commercial pop I'm like bro like
traumatized like I'll be my I'll be one
of my kids will show me something
oh hey watch this youtube video and so
they're like I'll go oh cool let me see
and they pass me their phone or whatever
okay play and I'll pop some
advertisement yeah and I'll throw the
phone at the wall you get a job and get
YouTube premium anyways don't forget
about psychological warfare iTunes
Google Play and be three platforms a
little something to help you maintain
your discipline when it counts and also
to help you maintain your discipline we
got flip side canvas which is owned by a
Dakota Meyer you help you visually
maintain your discipline also got a
warrior kid stuff on there we got miking
the Dragons stuff on there all kinds of
good stuff on flipside canvas calm as
far as books go got some books we got
the leadership strategy and tactics
Field Manual thank you everyone for
getting that book appreciate it it's
live now in stores everywhere
if you need to get some for every single
human being that you know you can get
them they're available got where the
warrior Kid 3 and where the warrior Kid
2 and where the quarry where could one
so check those out as well if you have a
kid if you know a kid if you want to
help a kid if you want to help a kid
become a better human being and to
literally have a better life and get
them those books miking the Dragons same
thing kids are scared the world is a
horrible place let them learn how to
overcome their fear miking the Dragons
discipline because freedom field manual
how to get after it
extreme ownership dichotomy a leadership
myself and my brother lave babban
talking about the principles that we
learned
combat and how you can apply them into
your business and into your life too you
can also have one of us come and talk to
your company one of us on the Echelon
front team you know who they are and
what we do is solve problems through
leadership so go to Ashland front comm
for details on that EF online leadership
training is not an inoculation you need
to follow up you need to drill and the
way you do that is with EF online.com
interactive leadership training we have
the muster muster coming up go to
extreme ownership comm if you want to
come to a two-day seminar conference
engagement about leadership there's
three from this year every one that
we've ever done has sold out these are
gonna sell out too and once they sell
out you can't come and there's nothing
we can do about it we can't like we have
the space and then it sells out there's
no more space so from one o connell go
to extreme ownership calm and an EF
overwatch an EF Legion if you need
people at your business that know how to
win and know how to lead and understand
extreme ownership and the principles
they're in then go to EF EF Legion or EF
overwatch and if you are a military
veteran transitioning out of the
military and transitioning into your
next mission go to EF overwatch or EF
Legion and we will connect you with the
company that is awaiting for you to come
and lead and if you want to hear more
from echo Charles if you want to hear
more from me if you have a question a
comment and answer then you can get in
touch with us through the interwebs on
Twitter on Instagram and on the face
auch echo is adequate Charles and I am
at Jocko willing and a thanks to
everyone for listening to this podcast a
podcast that would not be possible
without your
so thanks for listening and thanks for
spreading the word and thanks for
telling your friends and thanks for
getting some deaf core gear or some
origin gear all of which supports the
podcast and of course the true reason
for this podcasts existence is because
of the safety and security we receive
from the soldiers sailors airmen and
Marines who defend us with their very
lives so thanks to all of you and to our
police and law enforcement our
firefighters and paramedics our EMTs and
dispatchers our correctional officers
and Border Patrol and Secret Service and
all of you first responders you also
provide us with safety and security and
we thank you for that and to everyone
else out there remember remember that
like what Patton said all heroes are not
storybook combat fighters know every
single man plays a vital role everybody
has a job to do every man is a vital
link in a great chain every man does his
job so don't every think that the job
that you're doing is unimportant you're
playing a role then Patton makes it
clear that when you're doing your job
the key is don't ever let up don't ever
let up instead every minute of every day
go out there then get after it and until
next time this is echo and Jocko out